is with us right now to talk about
something kind of exciting especially
for people hurting
uh with eight percent unemployment and a
lot of people wondering when their jobs
are going to be allowed are they allowed
to go back to work
uh leader mccarthy are we are we getting
closer
uh and closer to some type of relief
package
well we're trying especially on the
republican side just yesterday
we put on the floor more money for ppp
that is
for the small business owner for the
employee the money goes but
unfortunately the democrats voted that
down
so we've gone one step further we
created a discharge petition
with congressman steve chabot and jamie
herrera butler
and if you get 218 signatures
on it it goes around pelosi and could
actually come to the floor
and just the other day a number of
democrats sent a letter to the speaker
because she has been the common
denominator holding this money up
not just for small businesses but for
schools for states for the airlines and
you know you begin to wonder is she
doing this because she wants the economy
to fail before november
why would she hold it up all this time
even in august she said she would not
let us leave without finishing
but she sent us home then she called us
back for an emergency
but not for covet relief bill and
republicans again
at that time put another proposal on the
floor of the house and the democrats
voted it down
it is shocking to think that it could be
political this short
before an election but that's just the
way washington is
right now leader mccarthy you know that
in fact it's to the point where
um after the debate on tuesday night
the president said that he was able to
hold
joe biden accountable for his 47 years
in power and now because it was so
interruptery
apparently the presidential commission
on debates is considering
changing the rules changing the
structure
they might change the amount of time a
candidate could speak
or the moderator might actually have a
mute button
you know in this country we want to hear
both what both of those men have to say
do you think a mute button is a good
idea and then
you know the guy who pushes it you're
going to wonder what was his agenda
it becomes way too complicated doesn't
it you know
joe biden's campaign uses a mute button
on joe biden every
day where they put that lid on it seven
of the last 14 days
so he's used to it but the american
people are not if you're going to run
for the free leader of this world
we want to hear what you say but now
we're going to allow one person a
moderator to determine what the american
people
can hear from our candidates of course
they want to change the rules
anything that gives joe biden some type
of advantage
and one thing i would say is don't put a
mute button on joe biden and for the
president
don't interrupt him because every time i
watched him speaking he couldn't finish
his sentence
you looked into his eyes i mean i've
spent a lot of time with joe biden when
he was vice president
this is not the same man that i used to
have breakfast with
i want to continue i want to talk about
the supreme court but i want to go back
to the ppp really quickly you said 218
signatures are needed
to get around nancy pelosi how close are
you to that
we're very close because think there's
200 republicans they're all
going to sign it we have a number of
democrats that have also become so
frustrated
because they're hearing back home from
their constituents of the pain that is
being caused by nancy pelosi
continuing to hold it up and she's done
this with every
coveted relief bill we had remember in
front of that refrigerator when we
needed more money for it
and she said no or when she flew back
and held it up for another week so the
kennedy con center
could have more money but more people
got laid off but what's very interesting
is the power that nancy pelosi has over
these democrats
when the republicans put it on the floor
yesterday max rose voted against ppp
he talks one game in the district and
votes with nancy pelosi
inside the house that is what's wrong
that's why the american people need to
call
every one of their members of congress
and ask them have they signed the
discharge petition
because nancy pelosi even released us
from not voting last friday because that
was the first day we could start signing
it
because she did not want members to sign
that document
do they realize this can't be political
because we know so many people here in
new york that
the companies continue to keep them on
the payroll for for many months during
covid
and then they finally just said look we
can't afford to keep doing this most
small businesses couldn't
and so those workers now they can't pay
their bills
they're stressed they're worried and
they can't get another job because most
people aren't hiring right now because
of all the
all the layoffs and they can't afford to
hire new people i mean this is so
important why do you how long is she
going to hold it up if it is her fault
well this is this is so frustrating to
me because every time we've been able to
have the four leaders in the room
we came out with an agreement but nancy
pelosi is the person that has taken over
this relief package and that is the
common denominator why nothing has
happened right because she holds her
members so tight
the only mechanism and rule we have in
the house to go around her
is a discharge petition the only other
way is to remove
nancy pelosi from speaker if people go
to takethehouse.com they could do
something about that right but what we
really need to do is put the pressure on
her
steve shabbat as a small business has
been able to put a bill forward that
gives greater flexibility we've saved
more than
50 million jobs and you are right it
goes to every single community and it
doesn't matter if you're republican
democrat right
woman or man black or white or brown it
does not matter
we're all americans in this battle right
i like to see it seems like the leaders
are you're getting closer uh mnuchin and
pelosi are talking and maybe uh
we'll get something in between 1.5
trillion and 2 trillion
meanwhile chuck schumer let everybody
know what is really on the table
we could focus on this confirmation of
uh justice could be associate justice
barrett if she is confirmed
but he's saying that if they win the
senate and win the white house
this country will change listen
on dc and puerto rico particularly if
puerto rico votes for it
dc already has voted for it and wanted
love to make them states okay and as for
the filibuster
i didn't i'm not busting my by chops to
become majority leader to do very little
or nothing we are going to get a whole
lot done and as i've said
everything everything is on the table so
that
packing the court adding two states
democratic states at least initially
four more senators they could even uh
they could even
expand the number of members in the
house
to fatten their advantage in democratic
areas
i mean that's literally on the table
he's saying this
he's not saying we've warned you about
in commitment to america that they would
dismantle this nation
packing the courts putting new states in
just to give them advantage of more
members
that's not the american way that's why
people need to get out and vote
but to really do this about amy cohen
barrett i mean
think of of her own life of what she's
been able to achieve and attack her on
her faith
she deserves to be on the supreme court
but you know where i really saw it
sitting on the couch watching my own
daughter megan her eyes light up as a
young woman
seeing what this lady has been able to
achieve not only in the courts not only
first in her class in notre dame
but clerking at the supreme court but
being a mother having
faith she's going to break ceilings just
like ruth bader ginsburg did
and the idea that you cannot be a woman
who breaks ceilings only because of your
philosophical beliefs
that's un-american and it's vile that
they even try to do this
yeah schumer could break the country it
is uh political as it all is
uh leader mccarthy thank you very much
for starting your day with fox and
friends
thank you